a big reason why
mortal kombat has found a niche where
other fighting game franchises have
failed is because it's so awesomely
and unapologetically brutal for as long
as there's been mortal combat there's
been
controversy over the game's many wildly
brutal finishing moves called fatalities
while there are just way too many gory
ones to mention
here are my picks for 5 of the very best
huge disclaimer for violence score and
cursing right here
you've been warned molina is a
terrifying badass
and screenshots really don't do her
justice
she might rock a tiny pink outfit like
nobody else but
that veil on her face is not there to
increase her seductive allure
instead its main purpose is to disguise
the fact that there's no bottom to her
[ __ ] face
like there's practically nothing there
just gigantic teeth which she will use
to gnaw your damn face off before
spitting it out
making satisfied eating noises and
laughing over your bloody headless
corpse
it's fair enough that you'd want to
watch out for your opponent's gigantic
teeth as deadly weapons but our next
combatant quan chi will have you fearing
the blunt pounding force of your own leg
in mortal kombat 4 quan she isn't quite
satisfied with simply humiliating you
via the method of diminishing your
health bar first
instead the evil sorcerer opts to forgo
his magical prowess
and instead fries off your leg and then
beats you to death with it
and all that happens to the glorious
sound effects of your blood pouring out
everywhere
even when you're clearly down and out
this sadistic dude will continue to beat
the crap
out of you another eight or nine times
if characters losing their faces and
limbs just isn't doing it for you then
how about a full-on
body annihilation literally right down
to the bone
raiden might share thor's dominion over
the elements of thunder and lightning
but much like quan chi sometimes you
don't need your fancy powers to get the
job done
especially when you're also blessed with
mythically tough punches that can
literally disintegrate a foe into a bag
of bones but like
without the bag shiva might not be a
go-to character for a lot of people
since she isn't quite as tough as some
of the other fighters but
she does have a killer fatality in
mortal kombat 3 the forearmed denizen
of death grabs you with all four of her
upper limbs and
rips your skin right off raiden might
explode you into individual bony bits
but
shiva peels you like a goddamn banana
and leaves you standing there screaming
in pain with all your gory bloody bits
still attached
while your skin suit crumbles into a
heap on the ground
eww earning the top spot is
mortal kombat favorite subzero who's
credited with the fatality colloquially
referred to
as the esrb maker first up a short
history lesson
the mortal kombat series had parents
everywhere enraged by the idea of their
children seeing such
extreme violence and gore in their video
games
and this fatality from sub-zero was the
final straw
the brutality of sub-zero tearing his
opponent's head off in a flurry of blood
with the spine still attached
was enough to spur on the creation of
the entertainment
software rating board it's their job to
decide what content is appropriate for
what age group and they're still rating
all your games today
for that alone we have to give the top
spot to sub-zero
so congratulations you sadistic brutal
son of a [ __ ]
let me know if you think mortal kombat's
fatalities are pretty cool
or too violent which one is your
favorite and what awesome ones did i
miss out on i'll catch you again next
week